ça fait dur ma cuillère j'ai passé en
bas savez quoi je vais aller au bal avec
l'époux que j'ai sur la tête je vais
leur match mais je comprends pas bougé
il a dit on va plus le mettre dans les
très bas qu'il a évoqué avec trois mois
j'ai pas je veux même pas demandé le
résultat du match
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont fait
match nul 0 à 0 et à la mi temps
ben quoi ob robert c'est vrai que tu es
mon ami oh bien sûr je suis ton ami tu
ne sais pas c'est pareil pour je le
répète tous les jours
bien sûr et c'est vrai que c'est mon
frère et comme je suis ton frère bien
sûr je suis ton frère si je trie même
marqué sur un papier je suis ton frère
ballon dans ces conditions est ce que tu
es capable de garder un secret un secret
entre nous c'est la moindre des choses
enrico si tu me dis que c'est un secret
si tu me dis que c'est un secret tu sais
ce que moi je suis un tombeau puisque
c'est un tombeau je suis un tombeau
alors écoute moi oui oui je vais
t'avouer quelque chose
ouais j'ai besoin de 500 francs alors je
vais te dire c'est comme si jamais rien
entendu
allez arrête de permis du aux agresseurs
voici la vérité est si je compte sur toi
moi je t'ai jamais embêté mois sur des
questions d'une question d'argent mois
ne savait pas qui m'adresser s'est fait
peur si c'est une adresse que tu veux ça
je peux te donner une adresse est ce que
ça donnait la neige j'ai compris j'ai
compris à quoi on a un ami on compte sur
lui comme ça qu'ils nous répondent bravo
bravo bien sûr mais c'est sympa mais
c'est plus joué sur toulouse mais sorti
ça s'abroge est sorti au bout d'un
moment on voit et que je te supplie ne
m'en parle plus et moi je tends
causerait jamais
arrête de pleurer arrête de pleurer je
n'ai pas demandé une fortune 1 millions
j'ai demandé 500 et 600 francs mais où
je vais sortir ou tu veux morocco où
j'ai des frais et des dépenses des
chartes des parcs des cotisants et que
je pense du puits soit gentil ne manque
aux plus et moi j'y ferai plus allusion
voilà on est comme ça coûte moins robert
j'ai jamais insisté mois pour les
questions de la raison est que si en
train de faire maintenant n'est jamais
insisté mais moi je te dis une chose
écoute moi bien calmement si tu me les
prêtres et 530 une perdre arrière voilà
moi je balance moi j'aime apprendre le
bonheur tu me les prêts dans un mois je
te rend le double de quoi pourquoi
attends tu m'as dit que tu m'as dit que
si par hasard j'avais 500 points qui les
prêtent ces hasards supposant un droit
tu me rends à la fin du mois tu me rends
mille francs ouais ça il comprend vite
hein c'est exactement ça c'est cool tu
sais justement je sais pas comment je
vais faire est justement j'ai cinq
enfants sur moi mais c'est pas à moi de
juger les rendent à kuito je pense que
je devais le languedoc à 8 au calypso
mais non c'est la vérité je lui dois
mais je ne sais pas qu'est ce que je
voulais raconter je vais te le traité
mais tu le dis rien tu dis rien comme ça
la fin du mois tous me rendant les mois
seulement prête les mois et après on
verra bien à la fin du mois mais c'est
pour toi mais moi j'ai une parole et
mais attends attends attends j'ai
quelque chose de mieux à ce gros projet
enrico jeu reprend 6 500 francs comme ça
la fin du mois tout le monde devra plus
que 500
phillip danault guardia